question est donc posée téléréalité
tremplin ou déclin et pour en parler
avec toi il ya vanessa lawrens bonsoir
alors qu'elle a été greffé quelques
émissions pas mal j'ai commencé par
l'île de la tentation les anges de la
télé-réalité 5,6 les ch'tis y en a eu
plusieurs
vous avez fait la totale après une vraie
spécialiste
sarah prêt souhaité avec le bon sens à
vous pour vous de la tonalité set plutôt
été un tremplin avant avant qu'on parte
sur le débat la télé a été c'est un
chiffre d'affaires de 1 milliard et demi
quand même en france c'est un
gigantesque marché et laisse c'est un
business il ya beaucoup telle a été
honnêtement ça faut qu'on continue de
fonctionner plutôt correctement même si
on constate une légère baisse d'audience
globalement ça marche aussi bien sur w9
que sur tf1 voilà les l'ena toujours ici
là il ya une base et une base de fans
entre 350 400 me des amendes parfois
jusqu'à 900 milles alors ces vagues
depuis maintenant 17 ans et je suis bien
placé pour en parler puisque j'ai eu la
chance ou je ne sais pas la malchance de
présenter pour moi c'était un tremplin
sont aussi benjamin ou le faux cul va
alors non mais c'est vrai que depuis 17
ans a beaucoup évolué et la télé réalité
à mon époque quand j'ai lancé l'offre
il ya eu un pic à 11 millions 600 mille
et la finale de secret' c'était 468 et
spectateurs il ya effectivement eu un
déclin ceci étant posé aujourd'hui ça
semblait devenu un business ceux qui
participent
ma foi en biais plutôt pas mal avec les
patrons de caudry avec ce qu'ils font
week-end les bois de nexter pour
certains mais pour d'autres c'est vrai
qu'il ya eu des katas et les cas on peut
les énoncés loana c'était très compliqué
fx de regretter il a fini par se
suicider dans lequel il ya eu
effectivement des drames donc la
question je pense est légitime
donc on doit la poser que c'est un
tremplin ou un déclin vous revenez ça
c'est une cata il ya des mauvais débat
en fait faut que j'explique pourquoi
c'est une cata au tout début parce que
j'ai commencé par les la tentation où on
n'était pas forcément entouré comme on
l'est maintenant
maintenant voilà je suis chez sunrise
magali vous vous connaissez tous donc on
est bien encadré et maintenant ça marche
bien mais non ça va ensuite vous êtes
entré en cadres et commercialement voilà
on oui effectivement on peut dire aussi
un peu aussi qu logiquement c'est ça qui
est un peu compliqué nous n'était pas
encadré on est sortis de là on retourne
à notre vie
tous les jours et à personne qui nous
aide qui nous donne un appui une épaule
sur qui compter même on n'a pas de
fausses promesses dans la télé réalité
quand on participe à un jeu c'est très
ponctuel les producteurs nous disent
vous participez après y'a pas de
promettre c'est pas une machine à
devenir une star après moi je trouve que
le mot tremplin l'homo des classes un
peu compliqué quand je peux pas
cautionner le mot tremplin pour les
jeunes qui nous regarde pas ce que c'est
pas en soi pour vous étiez coup de
chance moi j'ai eu la chance d'être
bourrée j'ai gagné secret story c'est
pas énorme ça après moi j'en attendais
rien de ce jeu c'est pas un déclin pour
vous vous débutez non moi j'ai pas ce
que le mot tremplin je veux montrer je
ne veux pas prouver aux jeunes que c'est
un tremplin la télé réalité font un
métier c'est un plus pendant les
vacances y ont participé
un peu d'argent un peu de monnaie by sap
bw est une fin en soi ça devrait
utiliser ce mot là beaucoup d'eau non ça
peut être aussi un tremplin ne suis pas
forcément des points il y en a combien
il ya combien de gens qui ont réussi
dans laquelle un jeune homme ayant un
guidage et nabila pour me laisser pour
compte voilà vous connaissez pas de
réussite mais je suis pas d'accord il
n'y a pas que des grandes réussites ya
aussi des petites réussites et qui sont
en train en devenir oui mais tu peux pas
dire janine petit une réussite c'est
faire du plafond de produits bélarusses
et il n'y a pas que placement de produit
je suis pas d'accord c'est un ensemble
de choses mais pas en tournage on fait
des rencontres qui pour le business nous
fait avancer c'est dans quelle pièce je
voyais un exemple moi aujourd'hui
bientôt peut-être que je vous ferai une
affaire à lyon grâce aux connaissances
on les remplit nos affaires et là tu
parle pour toi quand on a affaire
personnellement maginot défendre un
petit peu enfin de défendre notre
intérêt faut faire un message aux jeunes
dis pas que c'est un exemple
jeudi jusqu'à aujourd'hui il ya des
choses à faire moi à la base avant de
faire la téléralité j'avais quand même
un métier en main je gagnais très bien
ma vie pour être honnête avec vous et je
n'aimais pas la télé réalité on
regardait même pas mais aujourd'hui
depuis que je suis dedans c'est la
vérité bah ça m'apporte énormément je
gagne quasiment autant qu'avant mais
j'ai peur
baissez votre doigt je vais vous donner
d'abord c'est sûr alors certains vous il
ya eu il ya eu un déclin un déclin
physique et des excès voilà ça vous a
merdé à la base j'étais mannequin et du
coup suite à ça à la télé réalisé
j'étais catalogué personnage de télé du
coup j'ai perdu tous mes contrats ça a
été la première kata et la deuxième on
est dans un milieu où il ya des fois des
polémiques
même si on n'est pas forcément concernés
les deux dans ma des polémiques suivant
ton mode de vie moi j'aimais bien faire
la fête donc tu sors du lundi au
dimanche
c'est un mode de vie un petit peu moins
faim j'avais pas la chance d'être
entouré j'ai perdu mon papa au même
moment donc du coup il suffit qu'on a
une petite baisse de moral et puis bah
voilà donc j'ai été un petit peu touché
par tout ça maintenant heureusement j'ai
rencontré l'homme de ma vie et magali
hélas beaucoup y voient là un bâtiment
[Applaudissements]
un exemple de réussite de télé parce que
vous avez parlé vous eu d'excès ya quoi
de la drogue n'ont pas forcément mais
juste du lundi au dimanche quand on sort
et qu'on boit en tomber entre guillemets
par faire si je puis dire voilà c'est
pas forcément un mode simple pour une
fille qui surtout avant mais on va
demander à quelqu'un de tempérer
allemagne ce qu'il en pense gilles
verdez très fin oui toujours la femme
par de la pression c'est un déclin
pourquoi parce que c'est dangereux et
vanessa le dis il ya des dangers il ya
eu des drames de capa du moment où il ya
un seul drama quand il approuve que ce
mode là et laissez moi finir les gens
fragiles ne peuvent pas le supporter moi
j'ai aussi les vacances un choix de vie
ça veut dire que quand on repose de
faire de la télé réalité mois pour moi
en fait ce que j'ai décidé de faire
c'est j'ai pesé le pour et le contre
le avant et le après maintenant on parle
de mannequinat pour moi ça m'a est
lancée parce que au niveau des femmes
rondes on n'a jamais été mieux en avant
donc au jour d'aujourd'hui je me suis
servi de la télé pour mettre en avant
mais tant qu'on a quatre et ecully ça
dépend de certains cas je pense que
chacun doit se poser les bonnes
questions si vous êtes à bien entouré
par exemple pour les soirées moi j'ai
pas forcément tout le temps en soirée
tous les soirs donc après c'est chacun
comme il est chacun sa personne faut pas
généraliser ou madame isabelle il avait
ce qu il avait dit oui j par benoît
alors déjà premier non sens tu dis la
télé on peut s'y perdre et cetera tous
les métiers artistiques regarde les
jambes du jeune du showbiz
heureusement mais tu généralise tout le
problème de la télé-réalité c'est
exactement pareil il faut le faire si on
est très équilibré si on apprécie
entouré sur maintes rébus nabila quoi
qu'on en dise à un vrai plus jean-pascal
de la star academy si vous considérez
que c'est de la télé réalité début qu'on
peut pour vrai plus nous le dire avait
un vrai plus avoir effectivement il ya
beaucoup d'appelés peu d'élus
parce que si on le fait pour les
mauvaises raisons pour devenir entre
guillemets une star alors c'est
forcément un naufrage vient d'annoncer
manou phrase c'est évidemment pour moi
un déclin et s'arracher désolé mais
c'est vrai que les candidats téléréalité
me font beaucoup de peine et si vous
pour vous ça réussit c'est parce que
vous avez travaillé personnellement
nabila elle a travaillé personnellement
moundir il a travaillé c'est pas
seulement des candidats de télé
tellement vous fait de l'appeler moi ça
me fait de la peine parce que
généralement on assiste quand même à des
personnes qui sont diminués mais je fais
pas faire de généralités mais c'est
quand même des personnes qui manquent de
culture généralement ils sont prêts à
faire des choix faits par les jeux tu
peux pas une généralité c'est pas
possible que la cuve et chez des
personnes qui sont prêts à accepter
telle ou telle émission telle émission
telle émission la force de tout accepter
on devient plus personne théo faut pas
stigmatiser la tisane
[Applaudissements]
c'est une fenêtre de tir formidable on
parle de tremplin pourquoi parce que là
un business et une professionnalisation
du candidat téléréalité et ben bon
démarrage
benjamin en 2001 et à sundance et les
choses on y allait juste pour s'amuser
en tant que jeu de rôles s'étaient
présentés comme ça à l'époque sur m6
aujourd'hui communiqué je vous citer
quelques noms animateur sur nrj
ayem benoît si on considère quand même
ville mais assorti jennifer grosses
stars françaises
nolwenn leroy excusez moi un tremplin
vous êtes complètement à côté de la pac
parce qu'on parle de personnes on parle
de personnes précise la loi vous fait de
vous fait aussi partie de mon neymar qui
détruit les personnels et les chants
directement médias non c'est les
meilleurs oui mais parce que simplement
nous mêmes et après les médias des fois
ils déforment notre vérité ils déforment
notre qu'il ya une différence
alors oui c'est un tremplin mais il ya
des différentes tailles de taux plein
bah moi par exemple c'était un moyen
tremplin par exemple certaines personnes
c'est un énorme tromperie de route
non jean michel n'a pas encore parlé
mais j'ai levé la main surtout malaisie
évidemment je dirige il faut arrêter
d'en parler comme si c'était une drogue
quelque chose d'illégal latérite et
chemises jaunes et voilà il n'y a pas
que des drames des drames il ya aussi
des fonctionnaires de police à la pote à
son souci donc c'est pas la vérité les
gens se disent il ya des façons d'aider
à des problèmes de zurich 5e des classes
en chef des gens qui sont déjà nanti
caution déjà célèbres qui ont beaucoup
d'argent et c'est moi je trouve qu'un
jeune qui se trouve ce moyen là j'ai pas
pour avoir un peu d'autorité visant la
section peut prendre l'exemple de karine
ferri en fait si on est un peu malin et
professionnels et équilibrée c'est un
problème mondial la médiatisation en
revanche si on a une faille alors il
faut avoir l'impression que le familial
pour que ce ne soit pas savoir ce qu'on
disait de moi j'ai une agence de
chirurgie esthétique et en même temps je
suis sur d'autres projets là qui est ce
que c'est une chirurgie esthétique à
l'étranger j'accompagne les gens dans ce
lac ou pathologique à l' écoute moi là
je peux répondre une année vous répondez
à raquer formidable sur les médias vous
dites n'importe quoi des vis des médias
mais c'est sur ce qui vous a nourri
c'est pas léger pour y remédier à ce que
chante on d'expliquer c'est qu' à faire
tant à certains moments il ya des
personnes qui sont poussés comme la
honte
fx et loana dans un violeur anormales
parce que tout simplement les médias
sont acharnés pendant un moment sur eux
et qu en face à des fins à sortir et il
était mal entouré
c'est une société de fx est loin de là
mais c'était il ya combien de temps mais
ça la terre alors que les agents la même
chose aujourd'hui la situer sain
équilibré et que tu as far as télé en
disant je tiff je fais mon taf mais
après tu compte pas dessus pour finir
tally et que tu prévois ton après je
prie je vous dis juste en production
normalement quand on casse un candidat
très à l'iddri n'ont ils pas celui qui
pourra le dire
passez une fois deux fois trois fois
après test qui se posent quand le tas
comme il a été très bon départ face
outre la record recommandations des psys
dans tous les cas le travail est fait
pour le coup je me sens mal j'aimerais
aussi revenir sur un pont c'est qu'on
parle de tremplin mais c'est un tremplin
qui est quand même très bon call parce
qu'on a j'ai eu au téléphone les
personnes qu'on a su c'est ce qu'on a
fait quoi
[Applaudissements]
le téléphone les personnes qu'on a cité
en termes de support history et c'est
les personnes qui traîne quand même
cette télé réalité
même s'il ya des personnes qui ont
réussi grâce à un boulet fonctionne
toujours et qui tiendront toutes leurs
dépenses tout en images situé faire ton
image
aujourd'hui je suis fier de mon image
mais j'assume ce que j'ai fait a bien
suivi un temps ni oui ni non bien sûr il
avait poursuivi la belle pierre la carte
du minerai
on peut partir des d'avoir réussi
d'intérêt l'itc bertoia iliad mépris
auront là on n'a pas beaucoup de temps
je faire si on a un sondage juste oui
qu'en penser voilà ce que c'est un
tremplin ou un ou un déclin bon c'est
plutôt 70 % juste moi j'en ai fait pas
mal à traiter
c'est vrai qu'on voit c'est on peut pas
dire que c'est où l'un ou l'autre ça
défend évident à midi afin d'épauler les
années ça dépend évidemment des
candidats maintenant il y en a certains
qui ont très bien réussi car le receveur
a très bien réussi mais voilà elle a
fait une saison à l'as un business qui
fonctionne à merveille
après maintenant c'est vrai que pour
certains ils font beaucoup de poste de
business bon mais voilà et c'est pour
cela une expérience quoiqu'il on est
maintenant en maintenant en revanche que
je peux vous dire ça pour le coup je me
mets du coup je me mets un peu en
question et on est un peu responsable je
pense que quand on prend des antennes et
à l'été et comprend des candidats de
télé réalité il faut les accompagner à
la sortie et ça c'est un travail qu'il
est aujourd'hui a été aujourd'hui magali
berda
quoi qu'il en soit